joining us now nih director dr francis
collins
dr collins welcome back to fox news
sunday it's so good to have you here
great to be with you dana good chance to
talk about where we are with kovid
well let's start with that so it's been
a pretty confusing week for americans
trying to understand
just what is happening with covet at
this stage of the pandemic we have the
delta variant
it's spreading across america could you
give our viewers
as clear an explanation as possible on
what we should know
and what we should be doing right now
i will very much like to do that and let
me try to strip away
all of the confusing information and try
to hit the high points
and they kind of come in two categories
the bad news and the good news so let me
start with the bad news
delta is spreading we know it's
extremely contagious
and certainly in some parts of the
country like missouri
arkansas louisiana it is reaching very
high levels and we are now once again
seeing
case levels per day closing in on a
hundred thousand which we haven't seen
since february
so this is really a different virus than
last year and everything we learned
about
covet a year ago you gotta sort of hit
the reset button on
now how we need to react to it we also
are learning and this is not
particularly good news
that vaccinated people if they get
infected which is rare but it does
happen
they have pretty high viral loads which
means they could also
be passing it on to other people even
though they have a very low risk
of getting seriously ill themselves they
can be a vector
that was the reason for cdc saying it's
time
in those places where the virus is
spreading which is about 75 percent
of our counties to put the masks back on
when you're in
indoor space uh where whether you're
vaccinated or not this is the best way
to stop
the transmission of this very contagious
virus
so those are the bad the good things is
go ahead the good things
the vaccines work extremely well
including against
delta if you're vaccinated right now
your chance of getting infected
by this goes down by at least three and
a half fold your
likelihood of having symptoms goes down
by eightfold your likelihood of getting
really significantly ill in the hospital
goes down by 25
fold that's an extremely encouraging new
set of data from the real world where
we're tracking this
so vaccinations are still our best hope
and they are working beautifully but
of course we need to be sure more people
take advantage of that
so the other part of the good news that
i'm happy to see is i think we may dana
have seen a tipping point now
where vaccinations are going up every
week
56 increase in vaccinations
in the last couple of weeks especially
in those areas hardest hit
goodness louisiana has tripled their
rate of vaccinations in the last couple
of weeks
that means people are finally sort of
saying okay i've waited long enough
let's do this
and i would like everybody listening to
this this morning
to think about that don't you want to be
part of that tipping point
if you haven't yet gotten vaccinated the
evidence is now overwhelming there's so
many things that are
not going to be easy for you to do if
you're not vaccinated
companies are starting to require this
just let's get off the fence
move forward and be part of the winning
team that gets this delta
out of here i think the vaccinated
people are somewhat frustrated that they
you know they're they want to get back
and go about their lives without masks
and that's
it's frustrating to them when they feel
like you know here we are i've done the
right thing but now
we're going to be possibly having to go
back to this including in our schools
and and you know
masks aren't a magic bullet the vaccines
aren't a magic bullet but the vaccines
are working very well and i understand
that there has been
that uptick um do you think it's
necessary for
children to have to be masked in schools
as they start you know in the next
couple of weeks
well if the goal here is to reduce
transmission
of this virus amongst children who are
not completely
uh immune from getting seriously ill or
having them pass it on to others in
their households
the masks are the best thing we've got
right now to reduce that i know people
are frustrated and i know people are
frustrated and it's gotten very
political and people are looking for
someone to blame
just put all that aside and look at the
facts if delta is as contagious as we
now know it is
and we want to try to put an end to what
is a very significant uptick right now
wearing masks if you're under 12 and
can't be vaccinated when you're in
school
is a really smart thing to do and i know
it's tiresome and kids and their parents
are sick of it
but let's think about we're talking
about life and death here we've lost 620
000 americans already if we could save
even a few of those
by putting masks on ourselves and our
kids well it seems like the right thing
to do but at some point don't we have to
accept that there will be some risk
oh there is risk in being alive right
now for sure and risk in going around
your business which i think we are all
determined to try to do and avoid
lockdowns which is something we don't
want to have to go back to
but if we're going to be able to
continue whether in business or in
school
to do things that we all really value
putting the mask
on is the best way to ensure that things
don't get worse so it seems like a
sacrifice worth making
all right i also wanted to ask you about
this so i this is about my mom but i do
think this is representative of a lot of
people across
america so for the last she's 74 years
old for the last 18 months
she's done all the right things they've
stayed home she has on her bucket list
a road trip to new england she lives in
denver she'd love to see the colors this
fall but she's concerned
i think that as she is fully vaccinated
this is a trip she should take and
take the right precautions if she needs
to in a crowded area but what say you
about people
getting back to living their lives and
learning to live
with the virus i think she should
definitely go
i think she should do all the careful
things obviously wear a mask during
public transportation because that's
still a really smart thing and required
in most places and as you say wear a
mask indoors and crowded places
but actually new england is doing a lot
better than the rest of the country
so she's going to a place where the
infection rates are quite a bit lower i
would still urge her to do all those
cautious things but
yeah go and enjoy the colors this is not
a reason to stay home
at this point we've made a lot of
progress here compared to where we were
a year ago
we just don't want to do silly things to
cause the delta virus to come back even
stronger
all right dr francis collins a pleasure
to have you this morning thank you so
much thank you get vaccinated people